sona marin the prime minister of finland
has been under fire lately for one of
the dumbest political scandals
imaginable for partying and dancing and
having a good time the clips of which
were made public marin is 36 years old
making her one of the youngest world
leaders and good for her she likes to
have fun every now and then go to house
parties and nightclubs and dance
presumably have a few drinks and just
all around have a good time and she's
actually had to respond to criticism
over this both from the finnish people
and from people across the world there
are some right-wing commentators here in
the us who are making a fuss about this
saying that this is unbecoming of a
prime minister what if she was on drugs
what if there was an emergency that she
had to deal with at that very moment
what would the world have done and it's
clear to me that a lot of these attacks
are ageist and misogynistic because he
wouldn't make them about an older man
for example but let's first check out
the ever so controversial video of her
partying and having a good time
[Music]
all right so if you were just listening
and you weren't watching along there
she's just dancing and making some cool
poses and having some fun with her
friends there's really nothing out of
the ordinary about it but despite all
this she had to give a response to
reporters marin has said in response to
the videos that she's agreed to take a
drug test which i don't think that she
should have had to do or should have
been pressured into but the results of
that drug test are supposedly going to
come out within the week and she's also
made the statement i did nothing illegal
which is very much true and even in my
teenage years i have not used any kind
of drug and then in response to the idea
of like oh well what if an emergency
came up she said i don't remember a
single time that there was a sudden
situation in the middle of the night to
go to the state council palace i think
my ability to function was really good
there were no known meetings on the days
i was partying so this readiness to
respond if there was an attack or
something seems to be based on the
presumption that she was drinking and we
don't know by the way if she was
drinking or drinking to excess but even
if she was like this is not a standard
that we hold to other leaders other
world leaders that they can't have a
drink every now and then that they can't
get a little buzz going why is this
being unfairly applied to her and then
after the initial clips came out we also
got a clip of marin dancing with someone
who is not her husband and some people
were upset with that even though if you
look at the video the dancing seems
pretty platonic and she's actually
trying to back away from the guy who's
making advances on her she at one point
puts her arm up so that's the situation
anyway for her to deal with her husband
with right it's not really a matter of
public interest in my opinion but just
it's another thing that they can
criticize her for
and the big takeaway really is that
people need to chill out a little bit
and let loose and not take things so
seriously all the time and if you're one
of those people who are just too uptight
and you can't let loose every now and
then at least let other people let loose
and not take things so seriously all the
time and also let's apply these
criticisms equally please like when
donald trump danced to the ymca
people were making criticisms about his
dancing abilities right because it
looked kind of awkward but aside from
that no one was saying oh he needs to
take a drug test and this is unbecoming
of a president of the united states and
what if we were attacked at that given
moment would he have been able to
respond no one was saying that but
apparently people are willing to make
these criticisms against marin because
she actually can dance and she's young
and a woman and all these different
things so it's definitely a double
standard it's pretty transparent and the
bottom line is people just need to chill
out and apply these standards equally
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chilisleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that improve
your sleep by keeping you cool at night
chili sleeps cube and uhler sleep
systems are hydro powered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115. i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
it's fantastic and chili sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this you'll get thirty percent off your
new cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below